mesdames messieurs bon dimanche prudent
et responsable c'est ainsi que Christian
Freeland a qualifié la semaine dernière
le budget et la présenté aux Canadiens
la ministre des Finances propose de la
ciblée pour ce plus durement frappé par
la hausse des prix le programme
d'assurance dentaire premier au NPD et
des milliards de dollars pour encourager
la transition verte et si le
gouvernement diffère preuve de
restreinte ils mettent côté le retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire
ceux qui disent qu'on est en train de
dépenser plus il devrait dire où il
couperait parce que la réalité c'est que
les Canadiens ont besoin d'appui
maintenant ils ont besoin d'appuyer pour
les années à venir mais ça doit être
fait dans un cadre responsable au niveau
fiscal
[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous merci
aux finances Vous avez présenté votre
gouvernement présenté son budget cette
semaine il y avait un calendrier de
retour à l'équilibre budgétaire
l'automne dernier il y en a plus
maintenant qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ici
on regarde les détails dans le budget
Daniel on a déjà enlevé 9 milliards de
dollars dans nos dépenses d'ici 2022 et
dans le cadre de ce budget on a annoncé
une autre 15 milliards de dollars qu'on
va épargner et si on regarde le dv7
annuel l'an dernier on parle de 43
milliards investis cette année 40 et ça
va continuer à diminuer et sur le cadre
de prochaine 50 on va avoir moins de 1%
du PIB comme dafissat et si on regarde
les États-Unis 5% l'Allemagne 3 %
Australie 1,9% et en fait tous partis du
club de code de triple A et donc pour
nous c'est garder le code de triple A et
aussi ne pas mettre trop d'argent dans
le système pour booster les façons pas
de valeur ou c'est pas important
d'équilibrer le budget ou de d'annoncer
à tout le moins un retour vers
l’équilibre budgétaire mais je pense que
ce qui est très important c'est les
trois piliers de compte on va discuter
c'est-à-dire le système de santé
investir dans l'économie propre pour
avoir des centaines de milliers de bons
emplois pour les Canadiens canadiens et
adresser cette question de cours de la
vie et aider les Canadiens qui en ont le
plus besoin est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous en avez fait suffisamment pour les
Canadiens qui en ont plus besoin parce
que crédit TPS qui a été prolongée que
vous avez appelé le rabais à
l'alimentation là où
c'est ça est-ce que c'est suffisant pour
les gens qui ont de la difficulté à
traverser la période présentement
de tumulte économique que l'on vit mais
ça va aider 11 millions Canadiens ça va
c'est viser à aider 2,6 mais 500 $ par
année la meilleure école
100 dollars qui ont beaucoup et ça c'est
ça va aider 2,6 millions québécois c'est
clair et Madame freiner a dit moi je
l'ai dit à maintes fois on ne peut pas
faire avec le Pascal qu'on a on ne peut
pas aider tous les Canadiens qui ont
dans le besoin maintenant à cause de du
code fiscal les Canadiens vont
bénéficier de des soins dentaires ils
vont bénéficier de la stabilisation de
du système de santé emoji beaucoup de
sport pour ce budget et pour l'avenir de
notre complexe industriel si on peut
dire avec le fait que si on saisit
l'opportunité maintenant de vraiment
bâtir les comédies futures d'ici 10 20
30 ans on va regarder ce période quand
même une période de sagesse où on a fait
les bons investissements regardez
Volkswagen et c'est ça la saint Thomas
sont matériau pour faire un million de
batteries électriques par année ça ça va
organiser le chien d'approvisionnement
pour les batteries en électrique et
c'est le Canada qui va le point central
de cette réménagement parlons justement
des économies de l'économie verte et des
investissements que vous avez fait la
réponse elle fait une réduction hack des
États-Unis la réponse canadienne c'est
un programme de subvention de 80
milliards au total sur une dizaine
d'années aux Etats-Unis on donne de
l'argent aux compagnies on fait des
chevaux est-ce que c'est suffisant pour
répondre à au risque que les
investissements verts s'en aille du côté
américain on n'a pas à l'exemple
d'argent qui ont les États-Unis c'est
clair on a été une économie à moins
grande que ils ont
13000 milliards de dollars parvenez
13000 milliards imaginons ça c'est la
taille de leur économie nous autres
c'est plutôt 2,5
dans les femmes dans les syndicats pour
4 ans sur le gouvernement de Trump et
nous les Canadiens continuent à faire
des investissements donc avant même le
budget de 23 120 milliards de dollars
investis dans l'économie propre là on
ajoute 80 à 80 milliards de dollars sur
10 ans sur 10 ans donc regardons le fait
que sur les prochaines disons on va voir
un investissement de 200 millions 200
milliards de dollars et je sais que ça
fonctionne pas seulement à votre swagen
mais on regarde vraiment regarder dans
mon coin du pays avec airpods qui
s'installe 1,6 milliards de dollars
d'investissement pour créer le plus
grand d'installation des drogène propre
dans le monde vous êtes encore en train
d'être critiqué par contre justement sur
les subventions Vous versez à
l'industrie pétrolière vous êtes depuis
le début depuis 2015 ça va ça s'en va on
va les éliminer ça vous lisez pas les
subventions directes pétroliers vont
terminer d'ici 25 années quand on parle
de capturation de carbone c'est pour
rendre notre économie plus propre et
c'est vraiment pour utiliser l'argent de
ce secteur pour accélérer notre progrès
sur le carbone neutralité qu'il faut
qu'on fasse d'ici 2050 le programme de
soins dentaire que vous avez annoncé
cette semaine qui coûte 13 milliards de
dollars c'est une idée du NPD pourquoi
vous le dites pas
dit non plus c'est un truc d'une ça
non c'est ça fait partie d'une attente
avec la MPD mais il faut dire que le
gouvernement libéral c'est nous qui
l'ont implanté c'est nous qui ont
regardé dire 0 à 12 ans c'est bon c'est
un au début et là on va élargir de deux
à 18 on va aussi aider les aînés et
ensuite je pense que c'est une programme
qui est la hauteur de qui nous semble
qu'un pays mais vous en prenez le crédit
vous voulez pas le donner de crédit
là-dessus je pense que c'est seulement
notre gouvernement libéral qui est
capable de l'implanter c'est et c'est
nous qui avons agi garde les
consommateurs nous posent la MPD nous
poste les verbes nous poste mais
gouverner c'est choisir et on a choisi
de faire cette expansion du système de
dentaire et quand on parle aux Canadiens
canadiennes québécois il voit que c'est
une bonne chose à faire et c'est
pourquoi nous l'avons fait vous avez été
critiquer cette semaine notre autre des
conservateurs et je l'ai entendu de
d'autres aussi qui disent bon ce
gouvernement là il peut pas trouver une
pièce il peut pas trouver un dollar qui
est pas capable de dépenser comment vous
allez vous défendre d'être une
administration un gouvernement un parti
dépenser trop dépensier parce que c'est
ça l'étiquette qu'on vous attache
présente mais je pense que notre
gouvernement fait des investissements au
bon moment et quand on a vu ce que
Monsieur hurperfet sur 10 ans c'était du
coupé de couper du coupé il y en avait
une économie qui stagne qui n'avait pas
de croissance et en 2022 Canada avait le
plus grand croissant économique dans le
G7 et si on veut vraiment saisir cette
opportunité générationnelle d'abord une
économie propre de stabiliser notre
système de santé d'aider les personnes
qui en ont besoin c'est le temps d'agir
et si on fait la comparaison avec nos
homologues dans le G7 il prendrait notre
balancier demain parce que on est des
bons gérants de l'école mécanienne merci
d'avoir été des nôtres merci